[Music]
welcome back everybody to careful boys
we have with us
the lovely colleen lionheart everybody
lionheart
coolest name ever no yeah she's a very
careful boy as well thank you for being
here with us lionheart is such a cool
last name i was just going to say lion
and i'm a leo so it all just kind of fit
into my room that's cool lionheart lion
heart you're going to see that movie
with jean-claude van damme yep
he fights in parking garages that's
usually the next reference
that's what the doctor asked her when
she was born
big fan so have you seen that
is that where you guys got it yeah
anything with a ferocious beast as your
last name like what if it's like tiger
claw
that's your last name or nick honey
badger or white claw lion heart sounds
way better
is that your last name now it is
he just just bestowed it upon it it's
just as cool though it's beast and and
body part
so like
like monkey brain
that's not that i'm not sorry
like gorilla arm you know phoenix
feather awesome thought
um a kangaroo pouch
right no butt
no never mind hold on we got to workshop
this gotta work so what's ryan's last
name my last name is conferrido is it
actually oh yeah that's right i've heard
that before okay it's because they got
for jake how'd you come up with ryan
anime uh because
when i was entering b-boy jams like when
i first started dancing uh people used
to say i looked like a cartoon
and then uh so my name was ryan anime
and then someone called it ry anime but
then i used to spell it like actual
anime like i and ime but b-boys can't
read very well so when they would do the
call it the call-out sheet for who's up
next they would always go
ryan i'm ryan aims up now and then i
would miss it because i'm like oh that's
not me that's some [ __ ] up guy's name
never performed yeah
so that's some poor bastion
so the reason why it's spelled with an
a-y is to phonetically help the b-boy
community like john phonics commercials
work wow that's hilarious so that's the
origin of ryan may because people can't
read i thought it may was like your
middle name or something there have been
there have been people that thought that
emme was my last name for years like uh
yeah a lot of like promoters for like
like all the guys on quest i've received
checks as ryan
and i couldn't catch them yeah you know
they booked his flight as timothy
deleghetto
and he couldn't get on the airplane and
he was like i the [ __ ] i bet that
happens a lot time
that's really funny actually that's
probably why it changed his whole name
that's why i was doing john's all the
time just the rock
how am i gonna have tsa it's crazy oh my
goodness gsa usa
go to clear you ever run into problems
with your name being so cool
no never no
never
never just dudes wanting to marry you
and take your last name i bet
[Laughter]
my previous ex about how like if it were
to work out i'm not changing my last
name like i'll i'll put your last name
in the middle it's one of those names
that you don't want to change though no
no way what's gonna top lionheart yeah
as a last name not much lion dick am i
right [ __ ] searchlight
dragon soul dragon soul dragon soul
would work i feel like right tony man
right it's a workshop it's workshop
so the really cool thing is that uh
because uh colleen's a director and she
has her own production company called
it's called line
so then i'm sure a lot of people are
like hey how'd you think of that that's
a cool name yeah uh did you know that
john clark got damn movie
you're like yeah i actually did it i
made it
just wasn't born yet
um
yeah no i mean that's how i made my name
how do you know each other uh through
the dance world because uh a long time
ago she started doing dance content for
a bunch of different people like
collaborating with a lot of like really
like uh high up dancers including myself
as a director
yeah
as a dance director i film she does
everything well i started off as an
editor and then i picked up a camera
because editing got boring that i didn't
want to sit at a computer for 12 hours
and gain weight so i was like i gotta do
something more proactive
so i picked up a camera and just started
shooting dance did you also dance is
that how you got into the community so
you're doing this and then you grab the
camera
yeah you should see the shot that's why
it's all shaky
because while you're recording you're
just like yeah
you know it's her early work
and then later you just like i gotta
keep it still cause she's still dancing
while she's like
yeah
my identity crisis where are you from
i'm from l.a you're from l.a oh it's not
native a native yeah and that natives
wait i thought all dancers knew each
other you don't know each other i met
her oh okay okay okay yeah but doesn't
necessarily mean i know where she came
from he's like oh god okay good
[Laughter]
the legend continues you shattered your
dream of like how la works
are you in a dance crew no oh okay
what's your first impression actually
yes it's called lionheart okay oh you
are okay when you first met anthony what
was your first impression of really
um
just a question dude i was thinking it i
want to ask you a really good question
so loaded on this [ __ ] show to be
honest i don't have one brutally honest
especially negative it's completely fine
just forgot about it immediately right
exactly i was moving in the shadows you
know no impression was the impression
nice yeah no it was just in passing and
we were both probably doing like a
million other things and it was just
like hey how are you it's cool and i
believe you showed up to our banquet
yeah is that what it was yeah this is
our banquet what's a banquet like you
guys eat food and dress up and what's up
like not yours what's available
it's like our occasions or banquet which
like you know we throw i host i do a lot
of speeches but she didn't remember me
so that's uh
you know i i remembered mike's song
[Laughter]
there it is he's a great guy mike's the
memorable
what do you got to say about mike
absolutely nothing absolutely nothing
and most in most pairs of best friends
one's usually the memorable one right
yeah yeah
totally what
what
i just like that in this room sometimes
most of the time now when people come in
they're probably in a dance crew which
has never been part of my life
[Laughter]
it's like i meet someone it's like oh
you're in a dance crew huh that's
probably the craziest thing i've ever
[ __ ] heard in my life
i'm like so used to i'm like yeah you're
a dancer of course wasn't nicking the
dance crew what
no your wife no but she dances i don't
think so
if he finds out he's gonna be it's gonna
be a problem
yeah i hope not oh god didn't she dance
or take dance if you're gonna say what
crew she's in where on our ids where
oregon donor usually is it'll tell you
the dance crew yeah you got chipped you
guys are all chipped because that's who
they call when you're dying they're like
oh okay there's a chance that's the name
of your dance crew organ donor no but
that is true though i'm with steve on
that the first time i met a guy like one
of my what a really good buddy of mine
was in a dance group and when he told me
he was in a dance crew i had so many
questions about like everything what did
you think that meant i didn't know i
don't know
because my
my only perspective on dance cruise was
like the jabberwockies that was it okay
yeah
barely knew them i knew like those
[ __ ] dance movies and that's it i
thought those were whack
oh no
you never got into break dancing [ __ ]
though do you have to do so funny though
well no no it doesn't happen though
white people as much as it does asians
oh you mean no breakdance is cool as
[ __ ] yeah whatever i'm talking about the
dance movies though like honey and all
that [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah the ymca the
wreckage
you got to save the rec center there are
a lot of rec centers out there you got
to be you know there's a lot of ymca
keeping kids out of it great dancing is
cool breakdancing school as [ __ ] i want
i want hate on that i'll show i'll hate
on everything else though it's that
isolation choreography that [ __ ]
ticks me off within the dance community
give us a sample dude since we have so
many dancers and i know this answer
because i'm a dancer too but i just want
you know i'm just presenting this for
the folks at home dancing and the two
non-dancers over there not yet we could
still be dancers
kevin yeah what the [ __ ] we gotta chip
on our shoulder you don't think we can
dance yeah we can [ __ ] dance bro can
probably but i'm just saying let me
introduce you to the world because this
question is going to blow your mind all
right is there a spectrum
of the most badass
to like the most lame of dance right
and then do they judge each other what's
the most [ __ ] dance there is that's
really good like it's polka dancing yeah
does the break dancers like are the
break dancers like the bad boys of dance
like like the guys in [ __ ] michael
jackson you know how they [ __ ] like
they they uh they they hold hands and
then they try to fight with a
switchblade those are the bad boys that
dance you know i think like west side
story i don't know if it's so much that
they're the bad boys but they like jazz
they've definitely like they've had a
reputation of being the harder ones to
employ professionally because sometimes
they're late all the time
they're just too [ __ ] they're just
too like
they got a lot of pride and then you
know like right if you ask the guy like
like if you ask a b-boy like hey if
you're like a director like and you
wanted it to look a little different so
you asked him to change it slightly
you'd be like nah man then it wouldn't
be legit like you'd kind of give oh
so they're the rock stars of dance i've
been on set many times we're like so
they're the they're the french painters
of dance they're like very pretentious
the french faders yeah all right the
exact analogy i would use yeah today's
video is brought to you by expressvpn
it's super important to protect your
computer because if you're on an
unencrypted network and then there's
another hacker on the network they can
access all of your stuff they can hack
you they could take your financial data
your identity and they could sell it on
the dark web for over a thousand bucks
damn that's a lot of money man but you
know what's even more money your whole
entire life savings your life your
emails everything that you have on there
it can mess up everything and that's why
i'm super paranoid about this i got it
on my phone i got it on my laptop i got
it on every single device that i can
virtually have on because i also travel
a lot and when i'm hopping from hotel
wi-fi or going like into different
airports or foreign countries right like
i don't always have my phone service on
but it's easy to hook up on the wi-fi
there i don't want anybody to lurk
inside my stuff
get all of my dick pics and then
blackmail me and be like hey guess what
i'm going to show this to everybody i
got it from you at the hilton yeah i got
it i got your dick picked from the
helton you better pay me 30 and i'm like
i only have 30 dollars man oh my god did
you accept ethereum
can i send you my luna
yeah exactly
but that's why it's tough you know
especially you know when you go on a lot
of these like free wi-fi when you're
traveling it'll tell you in the fine
print this is not encrypted
you know so they're letting you know hey
it's a wawa west out here so expressvpn
is so easy to use you click it i have
mine just at the bottom of you know you
got all your apps at the bottom of your
computer mine's at the bottom right i
just click it boom and it's instant just
turns on and then now i feel way safer
and it's super duper secure it takes a
billion years for them to get through
expressvpn's encryption
and that's because they use
encryption tunnel you know it goes
from your data into the internet it gets
all scrambled up through this freaking
tunnel like i like to believe like it's
like matrix where all the numbers are
everywhere and the [ __ ] bullets are
coming this way and then neil's like not
today [ __ ] and that's your data dodging
bullets
from the agents yeah now they can
blackmail your dick pics for 30 bucks no
they can't so secure your online data
today by going to expressvpn.com
off the record that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
off the record and you can get an extra
three months free expressvpn.com
off the record but you guys can answer
my question what's the most [ __ ] level
of dance yeah what's the level oh you
mean style yeah style if a guy said oh i
do this dance like which one yeah where
does tap dance
i'm on the outside looking in so i don't
know i don't know they make their own
music when they dance they don't need
radio you know acapella right okay look
at this way like you have to be doing
tap at such an extreme level in order to
consider yourself a true like tap dancer
right but you know like you could be a
skater and never land a kickflip in
public you know what i mean like so it's
like that's the level of like same with
bboy you can kind of be trying it and
you can still live the identity and kind
of like write on the call sheet that's
what you're here for it could be your
lifestyle but you can't do a flare yeah
like
say you do tap and you don't do it to
like the nth degree like you're going to
get yeah
yeah yeah
because that's something that's been
around forever that like everyone can
kind of it's like saying you're a singer
and then people will know if you suck at
it
what do you think about b boys that only
up rock
you know what's funny is like arguably
some b boys that only uproad use the um
they use the pretense that that is the
most like hardcore and
what it looks like or they're like 80.
or they have back problems a brock is
like you never really get into
breakdancing you're just getting ready
and that's you you're done
it's funny because
that's such a like uh i guess it's such
a prestigious art form the the top rock
part of it but then i have been on set
or like in certain jobs where the
director or the producer was like look
at these [ __ ] guys just hurry up and
get on with it what the [ __ ] is all that
[ __ ] like they hate it yeah they want to
just see the [ __ ] explosive flips and
death defying stunts right away oh so
that's like the beat dropping in like
edward well it's just because they don't
understand it as much it just they gotta
is it because it wouldn't be legit
it doesn't save the record you know when
they're standing and then they're like
kind of like dancing and getting ready
okay so
this is the 90s style uprop you go here
and you go here you go here and you can
like get the one showing up
you go here and you go here it goes here
you go
and then you get ready that's dope you
can tell by the music those are speeding
up into the [ __ ] rec center like it
makes it go faster so you can do that
the right set the bulldozer just drove
away the receiver's gone
and you're still going through that
you're still upright
but when he does there's dramatic dust
everywhere yeah the guy holding the big
check is like i don't i can't give it
yet until he until he does it
that's the difference though it's like
breaking for for breaking is different
than breaking it professionally like in
the industry because then you know
they're they're basically whatever the
director orders what you got to do if
he's like spin on your [ __ ] head
that's the funny thing is not every
b-boy does head spins but on a set if
you had 12 b boys and a director goes
all right everyone spin on your heads
like they don't understand why they
would know what they need for the shot
prior to hiring somebody yeah it's like
they should as a director like you
should know
what you need right instead of being
like i'm gonna hire a b-boy who does not
spin on his head and the entire shot is
him spinning on his head but there was
like years of people not understanding
that that was like a different
discipline right
so but you're a dancer that understands
dance and then you can direct
so then but do you still run into
arguments with the dancers because
they're like no that's not how you do it
no that's never happened to you ever
no wow
you work with all the right people yeah
i do
yeah but you can pick and choose
absolutely yeah
i choose i'm sorry you love up rocking
right you're a good fan
that's the only people that i hired i
make sure that's like the first on their
list
all my ears are breaking i've never
heard someone go you love approach
that's so weird right i'm just trying to
i'm trying to learn man i'm just trying
to learn like millennium i'm trying to
learn about millennium dance complex i
see your career path just lighting up
right now so let's kind of dance because
we're gonna me and steve are gonna start
dancing eventually so we haven't figured
out what style we want to go to i think
for you guys you should start with
lyrical what is that like interpretive
basically i think right
i heard of it dancing to the like the
lyrics because the quality isn't is
interpretive as well you can get away
with a lot of whack [ __ ] i guess
well what's the most [ __ ] martial art i
talk about all the time jiu-jitsu yeah
probably it's just absolutely [ __ ]
you're just scooting on your butt all
the time you're just [ __ ] laying down
and hugging another dude the whole time
yeah it looks wacky looks that way but
it definitely isn't nice oh that's all
it is it's for sure the most [ __ ] is
the looks try filming it because it just
looks like
try making it look like [ __ ] crazy
that's why they don't use it in [ __ ]
kung fu movies or anything yeah we'll
pause
them
quite that as
[Laughter]
it's well done they don't fight with
jackets or anything like jackie you know
all right yeah they don't make jiu jitsu
movies anthony anthony what's the most
[ __ ] dance style that's going to get me
in trouble um no it's not no because
when someone in king just does it yeah
absolutely
whatever king just does it's the [ __ ]
one
i mean because because i do choreography
all the time we joke around about how
choreography communities like mad pillow
soft
you know what i mean it's just like a
bunch of very very sensitive intune
people that have to like share their
like moves with other people so that
they can empathize and like do the same
moves together but if like a battle goes
down or you're at the club you never
[ __ ] know how to break into
choreography with the person next to you
at a random track you know what i mean
if you're not like doing just a battle
routine but some say that you guys are
the bad boys of choreography
some say
i'm just saying like i think you guys i
think you guys are the leaders in the
game the bad boys of choreography we
love to uprock
no you guys don't need uprock because
you guys have everything ready to go
yeah of course choreography it's so
bright wait i'm interested about your uh
production company yeah yeah yeah let's
stop talking yeah the bad boys are
choreography i think you guys are man i
think you guys are the leaders in the
game i would like to move on because it
makes me nervous
it's an attitude era dude that's just
how it is that's just what it is bro do
you feel music videos or like yeah so i
started filming music videos dance
videos incorporating dance into music
videos um
but i've slowly progressed out of music
videos
it's a dying breed you don't make a lot
of money out of it
so what happened to music videos what do
you think yeah what happened is it tick
tock youtube
are they ruining music videos could be
the marketing though the money just goes
elsewhere
um unless you're doing
very specific music videos and you're
kind of one of the few top music video
directors that obtain those videos
um so the budgets are smaller than what
it used to be yes and also it's just a
lot of work for not a lot of payoff oh
so what's a better thing like
documentaries no
that's a lot of work immediately no
unless you're like
fully engulfed in that topic and you're
interested in it like i would what's the
documentary you would do
uh the bad boys of choreography
hey dude i got one right here for you
you guys should meet well
that's a such an easy skip like no
that goes straight to amazon prime video
oh my god with ads and just
i'd watch a kinder's documentary watch
your mouth dude so even if that was what
it was called the kindest documentary
subtitles the bad boys of choreography
dude
you're kind of like [ __ ] on my video
i was thinking about about a joke that
somebody told a long time ago
no that's all wait so do you do feature
films uh not yet also no right it would
be more what's your genre or what do you
what what kind of stuff are you
directing right now mostly action and
movement based so like my niche is dance
and and stunts
um so i'm moving more into that so if
you're gonna film jiu jitsu make it look
cool
how would you possibly good luck
add choreography in it
into the roll make them explode at the
end make them explode
a lot of the effects work add knives
you need an intense background for sure
something has to be going on in the
background because like everyone's just
gonna see this something has to go on
the best
backup dancers
just a bunch of mass illuminati people
standing around like it's a satanic orgy
some eyes wide shut stuff yeah that's
the problem right there she got it yeah
backup dancers imagine the henchman in a
jiu jitsu movie
walking up to you and being and then
just like talking
a lot but usually they start where they
just sit on the floor like this and
they're like hey get over here
like there's a there's a joke and they
do start like that they're joking the
jesus communities guys will start in
matches and they'll like stand up and
they'll be like this all right ready and
then we compete we shake hands okay and
then we go and then one guy
oh dude this would be an intense [ __ ]
i take it back it's kind of like when
you're trying to pass somebody when you
do it right it's different it's
different it's different because it
looks good you know because it's like
it's like you know
all these dudes and suits showing up
it's like dude we're about to [ __ ]
kill this guy and they immediately go
getting in a position like this come
into your car so what do you do when
you're fighting a jiu-jitsu guy he does
that what's the first laugh at him you
know what the [ __ ] are you doing you
stand up in the [ __ ] same time
he's like come on
go walk away no how do you attack that
you can't you can't so in [ __ ] so you
gotta like pass their guard and that's
what that means like this is their guard
right here this whole area and how would
you shoot that
we're gonna need a drone shot for this
one pov style you know that's how you
jli style
that's not bad that's not bad shot of
just a guy going like this vr
okay we got it
would be the first to do it but perhaps
there's a reason why yeah i think i made
my point thank you case closed
good we've successfully hated on each
thing everyone does
very good joe you're next dude
the bad boys of course season two
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you